The sauce, Kevin here with a game that starts out easy,
but quickly becomes impossible.
You can beat the best in the world at it and still not get very
far here.
I'll show you the goal is to get one of these checkers to the other side
of this line.
Ha I win. I just won an impossible game, right?
Wrong kinda. I won the, uh,
when the baby level, but it gets a lot more complex than this real quick.
This video is sponsored by mischief.
The internet explorers behind viral drops like the man eating food channel.
He started by eating noodles and then he ate Pewdie pie.
And to the times newer Roman font, it looks exactly like times new Roman,
but it's 8% wider.
So it makes writing papers 8% quicker or the mischief box that sold out in under
five seconds. It was like a Vsauce to video in real life.
The box had between zero and $7,000 of items inside.
It costs $100. If you didn't open it, they buy it back for $1,000.
After 100 days,
basically a massive experiment in expected value and psychology.
These are just three of over 20 drops. Every two weeks,
never restocked or repeated like an AI bot that texts you pictures of feet or a
collar that swears when your dog barks, most of it's free,
weird digital experiments. And a lot of it gets taken down pretty quickly.
So to get early access to drops as well as secret drops,
download the free mischief app, M S C H F no vowels. Okay.
Back to our game,
your goal is to get these checkers as far over the line as possible.
There are hardly any rules you can use as many checkers as you want.
And actually I got some empty spaces here.
This checker set only came with 30 and that won't be enough for my needs.
So I'm, uh, I'm not gonna use these.
I'm going to use poker chips. There's no limit to how many you can use.
You just have to place them under the line.
Chips can only jump other chips.
It can't just slide forward to an unoccupied space.
You can't just do that. They also can't jump diagonally,
but they can jump both vertically and horizontally.
So at least we got some of that sweet sideways action.
And when a chip does get jumped,
it gets removed from the board like that.
That's it welcome to Conway's soldiers. Oh,
and this is a one player solitaire game.
Solitaire is any one player game, not just the card game.
So get ready to social distance, your little heart out.
And the beginning of the video, I use two checkers to get to level one.
It's almost just as easy to get to level two using four checkers.
It only takes three quick moves and we've ascended to new Heights.
Well done yet. Still not all that impressive.
Two level three is where it starts getting interesting.
In 1961, mathematician,
John Conway invented this simple chip game.
It wasn't as trivial as it appears.
We can think of the chips as soldiers,
trying to figure out how to penetrate as deep as possible into enemy
territory, getting to levels one and level two.
Wouldn't take a whole lot of soldiers or sophistication,
but the deeper those soldiers try to go.
The harder it'll be to arrange, actually it doesn't just become hard.
It becomes mathematically impossible, which seems impossible.
If we have infinite soldiers,
why can't we make it to infinite levels? Firstly,
let's figure out how to maneuver one soldier from our tiny chip battalion
into level three, you'll need at least eight soldiers,
but you can do it in just seven moves in this configuration.
You essentially have two separate forces.
The left wing repeats what we did in the last game to get a soldier to
level two and the right wing sets up two volts to get our
little Rambo to level three. You've got to think about it a little bit,
but uh, you're going to get it for levels. One, two, and three.
It took two, four. And uh, hang on. I gotta make some room here. Hold on.
I'm going to try to move this without ruining everything for levels.
One, two, and three, it took two,
four and eight soldiers and we've got ourselves a nice two to the
nth power pattern here.
Achieving level four should be two to the fourth power
for 16 soldiers.
There also seems to be a pattern on the number of moves it'll take as well.
If we call the initial number of moves to get to level one.
And then the level two seems to be two N plus one,
two times one plus one equals three moves. Then we'll make an,
that number of moves and put it into our two N plus one
algorithm for two times three plus one equals seven moves.
All of this works perfectly.
Our two to the fourth power equals 16 soldiers.
We'll take two times seven plus one equals 15 moves to reach
level four. Finally,
we've got a clean easy system to get to level
four and beyond right wrong.
This is where the simulation breaks. We actually need.
Get this.
We actually need 20 soldiers to make it level four book,
slide this back on in the hair. I don't know why I
can't take it back.
We create this same starting pattern as we use to get to level three,
but it'll end up one level higher.
Then we play it out just as before and launch our soldier to save private Ryan
in level four of enemy territory.
And it takes 19 moves. Not the 15.
We expected everything I assumed was wrong.
Our easy rule on soldiers stopped working yet.
We still found a way we didn't have a formula for how many
moves we needed,
but we got there anyway with the little ingenuity from our five star general
MI, we conquered level four. I'm ambitious though.
Like Gangas Kahn and Alexander the great before me.
So what will it take to extend our Vsauce to empire into
level five, five?
This board ends at four.
I guess I got to make my own board sign-on checkerboard.
Okay.
Yay. All right. I did it. Here's my custom board.
And the first move that you need to make to get to level five,
nothing, nothing works for level five.
It's like trying to invade Russia in winter. Seriously.
It's impossible. Impossible.
I'll even link you to a website where you can try for yourself.
It's so weird having a limit of four rows seems to make
no sense, right? First learned about this. I thought this makes no sense.
We have an infinite number of soldiers and a board of theoretically
infinite size.
It only took 20 chips to get to level four and level five.
Isn't that far,
how can we not ever even get to level five?
The answer is beauty and
taxis. If we,
our target on level five with a T,
we can Mark all the moves around it with an exponent that shows how many steps
away that position is.
It's the sum of the horizontal and vertical steps to get there.
It's the Manhattan number, which stems from taxi cab geometry,
just like a taxi in New York city has to drive across a grid.
So do we,
and as we map out the moves away from our target,
think about the three types of possible jumps ones that get us closer to the
goal ones that get us further and ones that are neutral.
Conway use this weighting of each cell to have
to calculate, uh,
I need number file the maximum proof of why Conway soldiers can
never make it to level five is explained perfectly by Berkeley.
Math professor says to stack of, uh,
over at number file two and it's 42 minutes long.
It's surprisingly easy to follow. And along the way,
you'll see how Conway's game depends on the,
um, no, it depends on,
I gotta destroy my beautiful board. Oh wow.
Depends on the golden ratio.
The proportions we see in the natural world from flowers to the
composition of pretty faces and it pops out of nowhere in the middle
of the game,
but it turns out we can reach the impossible level
five and taste them.
And Gareth Taylor proved that we can get to the fifth row with the board of
infinite space, infinite soldiers and infinite moves provided.
We bend the rules a little bit.
All you got to do is manipulate time.
You really can go as far down this mathematical rabbit hole as you
want. But what started as a simple solo lattice game,
morphed into a metaphor for both expertise and hope
with nearly everything we do,
the first few levels are actually pretty easy,
but as we aspire to the more elite tiers,
it takes more soldiers.
It takes more moves and a more sophisticated configuration to
reach the top. It takes hard work and understanding.
And just when we think we can't go any further ingenuity and
creativity takes us to a place we thought was impossible
on April 12th, 2020,
we lost one of the greatest mathematical minds of the 20th and 21st
centuries to the COVID 19 virus. John Horton,
Conway was 82 years old.
He talked once about an object that existed,
not just in three or four dimensions,
but in 27 digit number dimensional space,
he called it the monster. He said,
these things are so beautiful.
It's such a pity that people can't see them. Well,
maybe we can't. I can't,
but John Conway helped us see the beauty of math in
everything, even something as simple
as a check and as always,
thanks for watching.
[inaudible].